so the fact that Jasmine's axes in her
life and she's hiding it behind my back
that's a big red flag to me
something's going on here
oh snap the tables
have turned
we're about to see how Gino acts when he
thinks Jasmine is cheating on him for
good reason Geno is starting to suspect
that Jasmine is messing around with her
handsome Australian ex-boyfriend Dane
which based off of what we've seen she's
actually not but she is telling him all
their business he doesn't want to have
sex with me Gino and Jasmine's situation
as a whole brings one cliche but
game-changing phrase to mind to always
treat other people the way I wanted to
be treated yeah they don't call it the
golden rule for nothing we're gonna talk
about it plus for kicks and Giggles I
would love to know your first reaction
to Gino twerking
yes Jasmine gives him the most
provocative workout sesh I've ever seen
excellent this feels more like Dirty
Dancing than exercising to Jasmine
let's get into it
[Music]
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissia after
Jasmine and Gino seemingly made up after
Gino took the prenup off the table
Jasmine tells Gino she's going to run
errands but she ends up going to the
park to call her ex Dane
no wonder she has trust issues she's the
one out here being sneaky Jazzy hi baby
it's good to see you what's been
happening
um
if Jasmine ever caught Gino doing this
her head would explode it would be this
can you do that
wow times ten could you imagine
when it comes to her friendship with
Dane Jasmine says she's not being a
hypocrite I can separate a romantic
relationship from a friendship I have
enough maturity to do so but Gino Dawson
but is she going about being friends
with him in a mature way if she's
sneaking to talk to him behind her
fiance's back and a question were she
and Dane this close when she was on the
show last season
where did he come from
all of a sudden he has booked a
recurring role in their storyline it's
so embarrassing but
he doesn't want to have sex with me
that's not good off the bat she tells
Dane about her intimacy issues with Gino
which is none of her ex-boyfriend's
business
but at the same time I can understand
how she's probably wanting to be
affirmed by another man right now
especially one like Dane considering the
fact that Gino keeps rejecting her in
the bedroom
I don't know any woman
personally whose self-esteem wouldn't be
affected by that that's hurtful kudos to
Jasmine for even still trying to give
Gino some he took away the prenup he was
like I'm sorry I don't want to lose you
but I feel betrayed Jasmine goes on to
tell Dane about her prenup fight with
Gino but she didn't mention that she
asked Gino to put her in his will before
they get married
should get that part out anyway Dane
basically gives Jasmine a pep talk
you're very uh confident and you know
what you want right so that's not a bad
thing though writing you say what you
want right which is a good thing and I
think that means you've got to end up
with someone who's confident as well and
I think you deserve someone like really
incredible I want to know the real
reason why these two didn't work out is
it really that Jasmine didn't want him
because he's too much like Prince
Charming
that's so hard to believe I really
needed to hear that because sometimes I
feel like
like I don't he makes me feel like I'm
not good enough yeah
yeah it seems as if Jasmine has thought
becoming quote-unquote sexier will help
her feel good enough I am the most
insecure person in the world trust me I
am but it is the inner work that's
really gonna make her feel like she's
enough which is why I appreciate this
next moment Dane slides in the fact that
she and Gino need therapy after hearing
all of this stuff
I think you should maybe try a therapy
he was smooth with it too speaking of
that you know Jasmine and Gina will be a
good fit for the new 90-day spin-off The
Last Resort if you haven't heard the
show premieres in August and it is
everything at least from what I know so
far it is everything I've been wanting
from the 90-day franchise they took five
past 90 Day Fiance couples whose
relationships are struggling to a
Couple's Retreat they get time with a
team of professionals who will help them
navigate trust jealousy and anger issues
this is great because most people on 90
Day Fiance could use therapy and that is
no shade at all there have been points
where I could use it and I'm sure there
have been points where you could use it
too yeah you've got to figure this stuff
out all right fast forward Jasmine has
Gino working out y'all less stress
huh
circular movements
like this
yeah baby but do it like this look at
your grip look at my leg all right go
ahead
what type of stretching is this we need
to have fun and enjoy each other
like this
[Music]
you feel now really
while it appears that Jasmine is
teaching Gino to twerk which would be
interesting what she's really doing is
trying to loosen up those hips yes there
you go
there you go
excellent
I don't work out very often anymore but
this feels more like Dirty Dancing the
exercising to Jasmine
[Music]
in a way I like it but in a way you know
I'm not one to be doing all this in
public that's going to help you with the
bunny movement
during intercourse because sometimes
you're like robotic
that's probably why Gino denies her sex
because he's afraid she's gonna keep
telling the world about his performance
sometimes you're like robotic we don't
need to know that no I'm not I'm like a
wild beast this is awkward baby no
listen Jasmine brings up how they've
only slept together once since he's been
there and Gino tells her again he gets
turned off because they argue so much
which
I don't know if that's really the case
sometimes I wonder
if it's something else
the episode ends with Jasmine and Gino
going salsa dancing with Jasmine's
friends and Gino revealing that Jasmine
finally told him about Dane
before we left the apartment Jasmine was
acting a little strange she was giving
me short answers and seemed to be
avoiding me
I felt something was off so I confronted
her about it and she admitted to me
earlier today she was video chatting
with a friend Dane I have been trying to
let it go for tonight but I am I don't
understand why she was hiding it from me
in the first place
about getting cheated on
but now he's suspicious so he brings it
up to Jasmine's girlfriend who tries to
reassure him that Dane and Jasmine are
just good friends she dating like in
2018 2019 if I know mistakes and right
before she met me kinda
kinda yes
imagine what Jasmine would do if I told
her I was friends with my ex
she would blow a knot
blow a nut I've never heard that so the
fact that Jasmine's axes in her life and
she's hiding it behind my back that's a
big red flag to me yeah even if you put
cheating aside you're with someone who
is okay with sneaking around on you when
I spoke to Jasmine last month she did
acknowledge that she wouldn't like it if
Gina was doing what she's doing I will
be pissed I will be mad and but my
definition of shooting is like you look
another person you're cheating on me
okay so in using my own definition of
chirin I have to be fair to Juno he say
like you're cheating on me at the moment
according to my own definition maybe
maybe I was I don't know yes maybe yes
maybe not oh it could all be so simple
if we just treated people the way we
want to be treated it could alleviate so
much unnecessary drama all right next
week Gino confronts Jasmine about Dane
to be honest with you I've been a little
concerned about your ex Dane
can you tell me what's going on
how often do you guys talk
once a week
are you serious
you're acting like I'm shooting on you
are you
no she's just trying to make you a
little jealous at least that's what
appears to be happening all right 90 day
fans fam thanks for hanging with me make
sure you stick with ET because we are
covering it all I will see you next time
[Music]